[Music]
hey everyone
my name is arjun and today i'm going to
be showing you guys 12 ways to win a
game of chess and 12 moves or less
let's get on to the first game
this first game was played between
johannes zuckertort and adolf anderson
and you may have heard the name
zukertort since he the name
the m the opening knight f3 is often
called the zerkator opening
at least it is when you follow it when
it starts with d4 d5
knight f3 this is known as the zooka
tour opening
so this game was played between zukultra
as i mentioned against adolph anderson
who was also once a very strong player
the game started like this e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop b5 so the roy
lopez
anderson chose to play the move knight g
to e7
and this is not a very popular move
probably the most popular move in this
position is to play the move a6
which is essentially just the main line
of the roy lopez
but knight g7 is not bad white played
the move c3
he's intending to play d4 and this would
help him gain control of a big center
and now black played d6 so d4
and this move has a threat of g5 and
since this bishop is pinning the knight
it could potentially win this knight on
c6
black plays the move bishop d7 breaking
the pin
and now white just castles black plays
knight g6 and now the e7 squared is
freed up
so now he can play bishop e7 and castle
potentially in the next few moves
knight g5 is played and this is not a
great move
but what zougart wants to do is he wants
to play queen
f3 bishop c4 and target this f7 pawn
which is generally a weak point
black played the move h6 asking knights
white's knight to go away
and now white played a slightly dubious
move he should just retreat his knight
and of course if you look at the
position a few moves ago
you'll notice that the position is
pretty much exactly the same meaning
that
if he played knight f3 white hadn't
really accomplished much over the last
few moves
but instead white played the slightly
dubious move knight takes f7
after king takes f7 of course white
played the move bishop c4
and now black has a few options he can
play king to e8
king to e7 pawn to d5 or bishop to e6
and there's only one of those moves
that'll leave black with an advantage
if he plays d5 of course then white will
just take a free pawn
so that can't be good after this
black will have the three options bishop
e6 king e7
and king e8 which were all present in
the original position so obviously d5
can't be a good move
if he plays instead bishop to e6 now
white can win a piece using the pawn
fork
d5 what this fork does
is it attacks the bishop and knight and
you can't save both of them
the best move for black in this position
is actually to play king g8
letting white have his pick of which
piece but be aware
if g takes c6 winning the knight then
you lose your bishop in return
so white should just play d takes e6 and
he'll be much better because of a safer
king
a great pawn on e6 and this bishop
that's on the same line
as the black king so clearly bishop e6
isn't a good move
in the game black played the move king
e7 and now white is actually completely
winning
but before we do that let's take a look
at the move king e8
if king he ate white might do what he
ended up doing in the game
queen h5 after queen h5 the knight is
attacked of course
and the only way of defending it is to
play queen f6
and now after this move white can play
something like f4
trying to attack he's he has his rook on
the same line as the queen
and now he's got a double attack on this
e5 pawn
on top of that white also has a threat
of f5
but what black should just do is he
should play something like e takes d4
and after f5 he can play something like
95 and he is slightly better
but that's not what happened in the game
instead anderson played the move king e7
and after this move white has a really
nice tactic but can you see what it is
i'll give you a moment pause the video
if you need more time
the move that white played is queen to
h5 like i said before
but now black actually is just losing
there are only two ways of even trying
to protect this knight and those are
king f6
and queen e8 not to mention bishop e8
if king f6 this move actually obviously
looks bad
because it's placing the king on the
same file as this rook and it's moving
it closer to the center generally
something you don't want to do early on
in the game
white should just play a move like f4
here and
if black plays something like e takes f4
then you can just take with the bishop
and now white will be mating in a few
moves
due to these discovered attacks with the
bishop
instead if black plays e takes d4 then
white can play a move like e5 trying to
block trying to open up lines
if d takes e5 then f takes e5 and after
king e7 bishop g5
mate is soon to follow
instead if king e7 is played what white
should do is he should just take on d6
and now because of these active pieces
sorry not that pawn
the bishop the queen and the rook
mate will soon be delivered
so clearly king f6 is not the way to go
for black
instead he could try bishop to e8
however the problem with this is similar
to what happened in the game
white can play something like bishop to
g5 and now
black only has a few options if he plays
king d7
white has a sneaky mate in one it's
probably not the first thing you're
going to look at
but it is queen g4 this is trackmate and
so is queen h3
and of course if you take the bishop
instead then
white has forced mate
checkmate
so bishop e8 is also not a good move
the last option is what anderson played
in the game and that is the move queen
e8
queenie a black white has two different
ways to check made in two
i'm going to challenge you to find them
pause the video if you need more time
i'm going to show the move now
in the game anderson are not anderson
zooker twerk played probably the cooler
looking move
queen to g5 check and now after black's
only legal move
bishop takes g5 his checkmate however
instead of queen to g5 he could have
also played bishop g5
but i personally think it's cooler to
sacrifice a queen rather than a bishop
and of course h6 g5 queen g5 mate
on to the second game
the second game was played between
hikaru nakamura
he's one of the world's best players
against evgeny bharayav
nakamura had black bari started the game
with knight f3
d5 g4 c6
bishop f4 queen b6 so far
nakamura is playing some strange moves
you generally don't see grandmasters
played g5
c6 and queen b6 on the first three moves
barrier played the move b3 protecting
his b-pawn
knight f6 e3
knight h5 so black is attacking this
bishop on f4
and since this bishop has a good uh not
the knight sorry the bishop has a good
diagonal
uh black obviously would like to trade
it off
so he plays the move bishop g5 trying to
not trade his bishop and after the move
h6
bishop h4 knight d7 he plays a slightly
strange move and also slightly dubious
move
knight e5 now this move might seem
strange at first
because after knight takes e5 and if
black plays
if white plays g takes e5 here's a
simple tactic
the move is queen b4 here it forks the
the bishop and the king
instead of playing detect c5 barrier
have intended to play queen takes h5
recapturing the knight this way and this
ends up being what happened in the game
now black played the move knight to g4
and now you'll notice that the queen's
diagonal here is now blocked
and actually the queen has no no squares
it can move to without being captured
this square is protected by the bishop
the score is protected by the pawn
this is protected by the pawn this is
protected by the king
protected by the bishop and protected by
the knight
so if black can just attack white's
queen without
giving away control of any of the other
squares then he'll win black's queen for
free
so white played the move bishop to g3
and what he intended to do here
was free up these squares but this is
actually a blunder
why had only one way to try and survive
and that was to play bishop to d3
now if black played a move like g6 which
is his original
threat white can play bishop takes e6
bishop takes g6
and in this position black is still
slightly better just because he's not
material
but white is not losing by any means
however instead of that as i said before
white played the move bishop to g3
and now black has a pretty cool way of
winning the queen
can you find it the first move is
relatively simple
it's to play g6 and if you play queen h3
as black
as white sorry then you actually can win
the queen as black
and that is by playing the move knight
takes e3 you'll notice that this is a
discovered attack on the queen
and the only way for white to save his
queen any longer is to play queen h4
but after this move the easiest way for
black to just win
is to play something like knight takes
c2 tinky two
and just take the free rook there are
better ways but this is the easiest
up a pete up a brook and a few pawns
should be easily winning
so because of that line varyer instead
played the move queen to h4
and now here comes the real tactic for
black it's a bit of a quiet move
so it's kind of hard to find i'll give
you a few seconds pause the video if you
need more time
the move that black played here is
bishop g7
and this move is actually so strong that
white just resigned here
now now that might make you ask well why
is that such a good move
you'll see why in a second black is
starting to play bishop to f6
so for example if white plays some
nothing move like a3
bishop f6 threatens the queen the only
move for the queen to
the only place that the queen can go is
h3
and now after knight takes e3 instead of
just winning the rook
after knight takes c2 knight takes a1
things are even worse for white
since now not only does is the is the is
white going to lose the rook
he's also going to lose his queen
because all the queen squares are
actually taken
up so that might make you ask
well can can white stop the threat of
bishop f6
and the answer is technically no the
closest he can come to doing that is to
play bishop e5
but the problem is now white will take
on black will take on e5
and after recapturing bishop takes e5
first of all the rook is being
threatened and if i play something like
c3
the only way of blocking this diagonal
black can just play a move like queen to
c5
now he's double attacking this pawn and
the only way for
for black for white to protect the pawn
is to play king d2
and clearly after a move like for
example castles
white is not in good shape because of
the following moves
white resigned after bishop e7 because
he sensed what was lying in his future
this third game was played between gary
kasparov against guy west
kasparov started off with e4 c5
knight f3 and knight f6 so this is a bit
of an offbeat line
more popular moves include d6
knight c6 and e6
but knight f6 was played and after the
move knight to c3
black played e6 and now this is looking
much more like a mainline sicilian
white played d4 transposing into the
open variation
takes takes
and bishop b4 now white
now black has a threat of knight takes
e4 since this knight is pinned
white white plays the move e5 and after
knight d5
he's double attacking this pin knight
what white chose to do is to play bishop
d2 now
so now he's double protecting this pin
knight with his pawn and his bishop
black took on c3 and white took back
with the pawn since now that the bishop
has to move somewhere
he'll have an extra tempo that is he'll
have game time relative to his opponent
after this move black chose to play
bishop f8
and after bishop d3 d6 white played the
move queen e2
now black played the very natural
looking move knight to d7 but this move
completely
loses can you see why i'll give you a
moment
the winning move for white is to play
knight takes e6 and this is actually the
only move that gives white the advantage
if f takes e6 is played the most natural
move of course
then white can play the move queen to h5
if pawn g6 is played the most natural
way of blocking the
of blocking the queen you can play
bishop takes g6
now if h takes g6 then queen takes g6
king e7 bishop g5 and the queen will
soon be lost
the same can be said if king e7
after bishop g5 although the queen is
not going to be lost anytime
soon it is lost after this next tactic
queen h4
so seeing all of these dangers black
uh white's opponent did not play that
move instead he
he chose to play the move queen b6
because if the queen moved to any other
place
then knight c7 would win the rook
queen a5 is also an option but queen b6
is played
and now after the move knight to c7
black simply resigned
can you find y i'll give you a second
the reason why black resigned in this
position is because after the move coin
takes c7
e takes g6 is a discovered track and
it's
therefore wins the queen after king d8
white will be up a lot of material and
because of this black chose to resign on
move 12.
this fourth game is played between two
very strong players
robert james fisher also known as bobby
fischer against reuben fein
fischer had white in this game
he started off with e4 c5
knight f3 d6 so the philidor defends
d4 and now he plays 97 which is a
slightly dubious move without losing or
anything
but more com a more popular move is to
play e takes d4
and this is the main line of the
philidor
but knight d7 was played and fisher
chose to play bishop c4
now black plays the move c6
and the idea of this move is because he
wants to play d5
and try and gain control the center as
well as push the bishop back
of course the move d5 is not possible at
the moment considering that white has
two attackers on that square
but that's just an idea for black to
keep in mind
white castles black plays bishop e7
takes takes queenie two just getting the
pieces out for both sides
knight jude f6 rook d1
queen c7 and this move is a blunder for
actually two different moves for white
can you find one of the moves or both
the two moves that win for white are
bishop takes f7
bishop takes f7 and knight to g5
bishop f7 is slightly better although in
the game fischer chose to play knight g5
if bishop takes f7 king takes f7
queen c4 is the next move and
if you play the move king to g6 then
clearly things are not too good for
black considering after
knight h4 king h5 knight f5 his king is
on the side of the board
and it's on and it's on the fifth rank
so white black will clearly be mated in
a few moves
however after the move queen to c4
black has two other options if you place
king to e8
then the problem for him in this
position is knight g5
and now after the move there are two
threats for white
queen f7 and 96 queen f7 is clearly a
more serious threat
since if you just attack the knight or
play h5
instead queen f7 king d896 is trackmate
and if you try to play rook f8 to stop
that the easiest for white is to play
knight e6 queen b6 and then just take
this free pawn
and now black king is in the middle of
the board white has very active pieces
and and for that matter white is only
technically down upon
so things are really good for white
however fischer chose to play the move
knight to g5 instead of bishop f7
and this move is still winning although
perhaps not as much so as bishop f7
knight g5 is played double attacking the
f7 pawn
and the best move for for black is
actually to just play move like knight
c5
giving away this pawn but fein naturally
didn't want that to happen so instead he
chose to castle
and now white has another tactic can you
find it
that tactic that white played is bishop
takes f7
now if rook takes then queen to c4
double attacks is rook and this time
there's no way of protecting it
after any move from white after any move
from black
white will take this rook and he will be
completely winning
and of course if you play a move like
king h8 things are not too good for
black
considering that after 96 queen b6
white could win an exchange on top of
all that he's already won
because of this after the move bishop
picks f7 black resigned on move 10.
this fifth game was played between
richard reddy and savilly targauer
freddy is is famous for the movement one
knight f3 which is known as the ready
opening
so the game started like this e4
c6 d4
d5 knight c3 takes takes knight f6
this is a popular variation of the carol
khan
queen d3 e5 takes queen a5
bishop g2 queen takes e5 so
earlier black gave up a pawn by playing
e5 but he used a fork to win it back
white castle queenside now he has these
he has the rook and queen
lined up on this diagonal on this file
and you may notice that it looks like
he's hanging a knight
but he has an idea in mind if queen
takes e4
then of course the move rookie one is
winning for white since the queen is
pinned and he'll have to give it up
but what about knight takes e4 that's
what happened in the game and can you
find the tactic for white
the move for white in this position is
to play queen d8 track
and this move actually forces maten 2
from here
after the move king takes d8 you'll
notice that this rook and bishop are
lined up perfectly
to do a double check on g5
black has two legal moves since there's
a double track the only way to escape is
to move the king
in the game he played king to c7 which
allows the checkmate and bishop to d8
checkmate
if king to e8 was played instead then
rook d8
instead would be mate
the game ended up by playing king c7
bishop d8 mate
in 11 moves
the sixth game was played between paul
morphy and alexander meek
the game started off with morpheus white
and it began with de4
e6 d4 c5 d5
e5 so this is a pretty strange move from
black and white already has some
advantage in this position
morphe being the attacking player that
he is played f4 hoping to gain an
advantage in the center
meek played d6 not willing to not
willing to take the bait
knight f3 bishop g4 f takes
bishop takes queen takes pawn takes
and now white has a pretty big advantage
here and not just because he has a
strong pawn here
soon he'll have very active pieces he's
ahead in development
and his king is likely to be safer in
the long run
white play bishop b5 knight t7
knight knight c3
now knight f6 is played bishop g5 and he
plays bishop e7 trying to break the pin
but this natural looking move is
completely losing black was already
worse before
but now morphy has a crushing tactic
that will win on the spot
can you find it
pause the video if you need more time
i'll be showing the move right now
the move that morphe played is d6
and at first glance it just looks like
this move hangs upon
but when you look at the position
further you'll realize that it wins
if bishop takes d6 like happened in the
game white can just castle
and at this point black actually just
resigned seeing what would happen to him
if the move like bishop to e7 is played
then white can play the move bishop f6
and you'll notice that this knight is
being double attacked
of course the knight cannot recapture
since it's pinned to the king and if the
bishop takes
then white can take on d7 with either
peace and he's winning
if instead bishop f8 is played which is
the worst move
white can play the move knight to d5 and
now the idea is that he's threatening to
play knight c7
and if if black just does nothing
then knight to c7 wins the queen
it wins the queen because the king has
no other legal squares to move to
so in this position what black should
just do is just give away his queen
but if he tries anything else to protect
the square such as for example rooks
c8 what bloc what white should just do
is he should just castle
he should wait to get his rooks into the
game and eventually he can deliver a
crushing blow with the combination of
knight takes f6 and d7
but as i said before meek instead
resigned after
12 castles which was a 12 move win for
morphe
games number seven and eight are two
morphe miniatures and this first one was
played against henry edward byrd
morphy had white and he began the game
with e4 e6
d4 d5 knight t3 so the classical french
d6 e4 was played which is not a very
popular move
two more popular and likely better
alternatives are knight to f6
and bishop to b4
d64 knight e4 knight f6 takes
takes knight f3 knight c6 was played
in bishop g5 so white wants to kick
around the queen a bit
so queen to f5 bishop d3 is played
and now what black should do is he
should play something like queen to d5
or
queen to a5 getting his queen out of
danger before it's too late
but instead he played queen g4 and white
can use a cool queen trapping motif to
win the game on the spot
can you find it
pause the video if you need more time
the move that white played in this
position is h3
and of course this move attacks the
queen but you'll notice that the queen
still has two other squares it can go to
queen h5 and queen takes g2
if queen takes g2 like happened in the
game wright played rook h2
and now the queen is completely out of
squares the knight covers
g1 and h5 the king covers f1
the rook covers h3 and
and h1 and the pawn covers g4
instead if the move queen h5 is played
then white can play the move g4
and now the bishop covers g6 the other
bishop covers h6
and the pawn covers g4 and the knight
covers g5 and h4
in the game after the move queen takes
g2 rook h2 was played
now black continued on for a few more
moves before white got to use another
tactic
after knight takes h2 knight d4 was
played and can you find white's final
tactic that prompted black to resign
this tactic was bishop to b5 check
and at first this move just seems like
it loses the bishop right
because knight takes b5 but if this had
happened in the game
well i could play queen d8 checkmate
which is a pretty cool way to end the
game
of course if some other move is played
like c6 queen takes d4 and now after a
move like bishop to d7
then white is already completely winning
because he's up a queen
and not to mention he's up a queen for a
rook and not to mention an extra knight
because of this black resigned after the
bishop b5 marking a 12 move game
game number eight is another stein it's
miniature this time against an unnamed
player
stein started with e4 e5 knight c3
knight c6 f4 so this is the vienna game
each takes f4 is played knight f3 bishop
b4
knight d5 bishop a5 knight takes f4
d6 and c3 so now morphy is broken
or not morphy sorry steinitz has broken
this pin
and now he's planning to play d4 next
move
bishop g4 was black's choice and after
bishop b5
he played a rather inexplicable move
king f8
which doesn't really make that all that
much sense
instead he should have played a move
like knight f6
but after the move king f8 white chose
to castle
getting this rook along this line and
now
black played the blender knight e5
white has a pretty cool checkmating idea
after this and can you find it
the move that white chose to play here
is knight takes e5
and this move completely wins
if black takes the seemingly free queen
then in the game white played the move
knight e to g6
and the only legal moves for black are
to take with the f pawn
or the h pawn but regardless of the move
in the game he took with the f pawn
knight takes g6 is going to be checkmate
instead what if black chose not to take
the not to take the queen
if you play d takes e5 then queen takes
g4
e takes f4 and a move like d4
or even just queen takes f4 simpler
now white is going to be winning because
he's got these this queen and rook
he has an extra central pawn he has the
bishop pair and a far safer king
so after a move like queen f6 white can
just allow the queen trade
and after after this he has a big center
black has lots of weaknesses and better
pieces
so white is obviously going to win the
game soon
this ninth game was played between harry
nelson pillsbury
who was a very strong player in the late
1800s and early 1900s
against someone named fernandez
pillsbury had white and the game begun
like this
e4 e5 knight c3 knight c6
f4 so another vienna game d6 was played
in this
this time and after knight f3 a6
bishop c4 bishop g4 f takes e5
uh what black should do in this mission
is just take back with the d-pawn
after which white will probably castle
or continue developing
but instead of playing the best move he
played the move knight takes e5
and this allows white to continue with a
spectacular checkmate
which you may have seen before from a
different pattern
i'll give you a moment to find it
the move the white chose to play is
knight takes e5
and this move wins at least a piece and
potentially even the whole game
in the game fernandez played bishop
takes d1
and it looks like he's winning the queen
but after bishop takes f7
king e7 knight d5 white gets a checkmate
very similar to legal's mate
and if you have never seen legal mate
before this is how it normally occurs
it goes with e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4 d6 knight c3 bishop
g4
h3 bishop h5 knight takes e5
bishop g1 bishop f7 king e7 knight d5
and this position if you look at this if
you look at the game position is very
similar
however in the game instead instead
of instead of taking the queen
black could have also tried to take the
knight back but after the movement takes
g4
taking the free bishop white is
completely winning since he's up a
bishop
he also has a much safer king and he's
ahead in development
this move after knight takes d5 marked
the end of a nine move game
which is one of the shortest miniatures
in chess
game number 10 was played between albert
pulver matcher
against jose raul capoblanca who was one
of the greatest players of all time
capoblanca had black in this game and it
went like this
e4 e5 f4
bishop c5 knight f3
g6 c3 bishop g4 so this is a king's
gambit
and instead of accepting capablanca
chose to decline it
f takes e5 gtx e5 queen a4
knight d7 so he's simply blocking the
track
and it looks like he's going to hang
this pawn which is true
capablanca chooses to sacrifice this
pawn but
instead of doing anything about it he
just continues developing
white played the move d4
and after castles if g takes e5 then 95
wins the piece back
but instead white played the move bishop
to g5
and now white has a and now black has a
cool tactic to completely end the game
on the spot
it has a similar theme to our last two
tactics so i'll give you a moment to
find it
the tactic that black chose to use here
is knight takes e5
and now if d takes e5 knight takes e4
and in this position white resigned on
move 10.
the reason is because if bishop takes d8
winning the seemingly free queen yet
again
bishop f2 is a checkmate in one
instead if black chose to play queen
takes e4
black has a different checkmate queen to
d1 mate
so after this position after knight
takes e4
black black doesn't really have any
options the best move is to play
bishop to e3 but after bishop takes e3
white has black has so many checkmating
threats that it's probably worth it to
just resign by now
instead if we go back to this position
what if black played a move like knight
takes d7
in this position black black could just
play bishop takes d7
and after queen c4 he can save his peace
or not by bishop b6 not by bishop d6
it's better to just play a move like for
example rook to e8
and the idea is that you're getting on
the same line as the king
and you can play like this
so as i mentioned earlier instead of
this
polymer matcher fell for the trap and
after 94 he resigned
game 11 was played between mikhail tall
he's one of the greatest attacking
players of all time
against rafaela vaganyan who was also a
gm
tall started with e4 e6 g4
d5 knight d2 so this is the terrace
variation of the french
and the main line here goes c5 but black
did not play that he instead played
knight to c6
knight gf3 was chosen by white knight f6
e5 97 white played the move knight to b3
and f6 and at first if you're not a
french player f6 would seem like a
weakness
since now white has ideas of queen h5
and getting on this weak diagonal
but f5 is actually a common theme in
openings like these where you try to
break away white
strong center
played bishop b5 and after f takes e5 d
takes e5
first note that the pawn is not hanging
after either knight capture knight takes
e5 and now this knight is pinned
so instead he played the move knight to
c5
now white chose to play bishop or sorry
not bishop g5 knight to g5
and the idea of this is to attack the
square that was once occupied by the f
pawn but is now vacant
tal being attacking player he of course
wants to checkmate his opponent out of
the opening
black plays bishop to d7 and after
bishop takes c6 which was tall's choice
black played b takes c6 and the reason
behind his move
is because if bishop takes c6 he didn't
want to end up losing this pawn
potentially
after a move like bishop knight c5
bishop c5 96
black wanted to avoid that so instead he
took with the pawn
but this allows white to end with a
really cool checkmate
and i'll and i'll show you in a minute
in the meantime pause the video and try
to find it
the move that tal played here is queen
to h5 check
and this is actually going to either win
a lot of material
or checkmate the black king in just a
few moves
obviously if king to f7 king to e7
queen f7 is trackmate so instead
g6 is forced and after queen f3 which
was tom's next move
aiming on the f file black chose to
resign
course this move threatens trek made on
f7 so black will have to do something to
stop that
and at first it may seem like the choice
is clear you should play something like
queen e7
but after knight takes e5 you'll quickly
realize
that the queen is now the one that's
protecting it so the queen is in other
words overworked
it has to protect two separate threats
if queen takes c5 then queen f7
king d8 queen f6 will win the rook
and because of all these threats as i
said earlier black resigned after the
move queen f3
the final game of these 12 was played by
geotrano
giochino greco who was a very a very
strong player during the 1600s
he's playing against an unnamed player
greco started with e4 e6 d4
knight f6 bishop d3 knight c6
so black is playing a very strange
version of the french defense
if you play the french you'll know that
the main move is g5 and there's lots of
theory after this
but knight f6 is not losing in itself
nor nora's knight c6
and knight f3 bishop e7 white played the
slightly dubious move
h4 relinquishing whatever small
advantage he had
however greco is playing to mate out of
the opening so his choice is
understandable
what black should do is play a move like
d6
simply trying to get this bishop out and
although his position is passive
white does have this small weakness on
h4
however black played the extremely
natural move castles
a move that many of us might play in a
blitz game but now white is completely
winning
he uses a very common motif here and
pause the video if you need more time to
find it out
the move that white played is e5
and you'll notice that this opens up the
bishop
so after the move knight d5 white can
use
a sacrifice often referred to as the
greek gift
the move that white played is bishop
takes h7
if king takes h7 like occurred in the
game white plays the move knight to g5
now his idea is he's got this queen
and this h7 square which he's trying to
attack
black has several options here and first
i'll go over the game continuation
he played bishop takes g5 in the game
and after h takes g5
black has a few options if king g6
then queen h5 will force mate in a
couple of moves
king f5 queen h3
if king e4 then queen d3 is mate
and if king g6 then queen h7 is mate
so king g6 was not the choice in the
game instead he played king g8
but from here after queen h5 threatening
queen h7 and queen adrian made
both black played the move f5
and after g6 taking away the king's only
escape square
rookie eight and queen nitrate checkmate
however black had some alternatives
instead of allowing this checkmate
the first and clearest alternative is to
play king h8 in this position rather
than taking the bishop
from here white should play the move
knight g5 preparing to play queen h5
and after a move like g6 h5 is opening
up this file
and white is obviously doing much better
and should be mating with the black king
in a couple of moves
but was there anything that black could
do after bishop takes h7
okay and king takes h7 well after the
move knight g5
he had better options that to recapture
if king if it came to h6 the easiest way
for white to win is just to play knight
e6
no it's a discovered check and after a
move like knight f4
you can just take the free queen
another option in this position was to
just play a move like
king g6 which is actually the best move
although white is obviously still
completely winning
white can play the move queen to d3
track and after
f5 e takes f6 king f6
queen h3 king h6 the easiest way for
white to win from this point is to play
h5
king h6 and to just play the symbol move
knight to f7
and after king king h7 queen d3
king g8 white is up a queen so always be
on the lookout for
greek gift sacrifices like this and the
way that you can recognize a greek gift
is when you have a bishop on d3 and
there's no knight on f6 to protect the
h7 pawn
make sure that these moves are also
available when you try a greek gift in
your own games
those are my 12 games for today i hope
you enjoyed them and learned something
and i'll see you all next time
[Music]
you